[Music]
hi everyone welcome is talk on Android
things glad you're still with us I'm
Adam I'm a product manager here at
Google
and I'm Amy I'd lead engineering for
underthings console and today we're
gonna talk to you about how to use the
Android things console to update your
production devices in the field as you
hopefully learn from a few of the talks
at i/o everything this is a great
platform for building yourself some IOT
but when it comes to actually making
more than one of something how do you
maintain that divide that device over
its lifetime how do you support those
devices once they're in customers hands
that's we're here to talk to you about
today okay so let's do a really quick
review of you know what is Android
things and why you might want it first
of all it has the power of Android
develop with the same tools that you
know and love you're an Android
developer this is easy because this is
Android afterall
secondly it scales from prototype to
production you don't need to be a
hardware engineer or a firmer engineer
to do this we provide fully certified
Psalms and word things isn't a OS P so
to use the stuff that we're talking
about in this talk you need to use
Android things Psalms the advantage here
is that these Psalms are built for the
platform so you just need to write
Android code you don't need to worry
about low-level firmware to drive that
hardware and finally with automatic
updates security is built in because
you're developing on certified Psalms it
allows Google to manage the security of
your device Google provides updates and
security fixes that you can implement
throughout the lifetime of your product
our goal with Android things is to make
things easy for you easy managed and
secure but this does raise the question
you know why is IOT so hard do I really
need to worry about this so think a
little bit about what it would take for
you to ship a few thousand managed
security devices you're gonna have to do
the hard stuff of you know building the
devices designing the hardware writing
the software it's hard but it's also the
special sauce that makes your device
unique but beyond that there's a ton of
other stuff you need to do to you know
how do you share development with other
engineer's if you want your devices to
be secure you have to keep up to date
with latest security patches once you've
found those patches you have to build a
way for your devices to get those patch
and then once when you how do you update
them in a safe way if the update goes
bad how do you make sure you don't break
your customers devices imagine designing
Delta updates fractional rollouts AV
partitions channel management all these
things you need for successful IOT but
maintaining and updating all that
infrastructure is a massive job so like
we said earlier our goal is to make it
easier for you with Android things so
the hardware and the software design is
still up to you like it should be it's
what makes your product special but we
make it easier because you can use all
your familiar tools such as Android
studio and Kotlin to do it but you don't
need to bother with firm work firm red
code because of the Android things
manage some model then when it comes to
security updates you get to leverage the
entire Android team here to find and fix
security holes plus with automatic
updates you get those security patches
with literally zero involvement from you
years after you ship your last device
and for updates we're leveraging the
same technology used to update millions
of devices in the field every day
hardened proven and optimized so you can
focus on the part that actually
differentiates your product the features
and applications that you write so let's
walk through an example to see how and
routines will help you do that imagine
that Adam and I are building a laundry
folding robot because let's be honest
nobody lost folding socks right so this
robot uses lots of opto recognition
vision machine learning which is a
perfect use case for Android things how
do I take that from a prototype at The
Geysers built at home and make it
available for everyone this is where the
magic of our console comes in and your
things has been designed intentionally
to make it easy for you to develop
hardware and ship it to the market and
you can use underthings console to take
care of all your needs first in
configure you will define a device
management group which we call products
and by uploading apps you have been
using editors like in your studio you
can manage your apps using app library
in console and using build functionality
you can create secure underthings images
with the apps that you just wrote and a
release tab you can push ximena's
updates to your devices and use
analytics
to make sure that you your release went
as smoothly so let's dig into details of
how all this works okay so the first
step in this road from prototype to
production is this sort of some details
in the console about the product that
you plan to build let's configure our
laundry robot first up set up your
product name and create models let's
imagine we had a few different SKUs
maybe we've got a UK just given to us Q
models let you break out your product in
two different versions now you next want
to pick your Somme type pick up some
based on the features you need and the
price point you wish to hit picking asam
is important because it controls a lot
about the image that you want to create
later one note though if you start
building with one Psalm and then want to
change it it's really easy without
having to rewrite a lot of code it's one
of the things that I personally really
love about our managed Psalm model you
can start with something really
expensive and then downgrade once you
want to cut cost at production or you
can hack together something really cheap
and that if the performance doesn't meet
your needs you can upgrade to a more
powerful song finally setup product
sharing - so today me and I are building
this laundry together we share access to
this product via the console so either
one of us can upload apps and create
belts once you've got the product
configure the next step is to write your
apps apps are the core of Android and
Android things is no exception they
define all the functionality inside of
Android things when Amy wrote the
feature for folding socks she did that
in socks that apk you can use all the
tools that you're familiar with as an
Android developer Android studio Kotlin
Google Play services firebase it all
just works because again this is just
Android after all once your apps are
written you upload them to the app
library so you can add them into builds
as you can see here we've got four
different apps that break out our
laundry robots functionality the app
library also takes care of versioning so
when you've got a new version of your
app the library takes care to show you
the most recent one one piece that I
really love about this is AB sharing
just like you can share a product with a
collaborator you can share apps to
Android itself is all about building
apps that others can use and Android
things is no exception here either so
share your apps with other people on
your team or other people building
similar products well today you're
probably only going to use apps that you
wrote yourself
as more people build on Android things
you might find yourself using apps that
other people wrote for utilities and
common features now it's time to build
images with Android things apps that you
just wrote in our case I wrote a brand
new socks that apk to give a Rosa robot
some awesome new sock folding
functionality Adams just uploaded to the
app library in the house all shared with
me so now that we have added this
functionality it's time to pick it up
into a build and flash onto your devices
so build is where all the ingredients
come together apps Google apps hardware
configurations that you may want to
customize for your device the setup
options that you have chosen here or
what we call build configurations and
build configurations are like secret
sauces and rules and configuration that
is specify the built the content of the
device image and by device image I mean
the images to flash to your devices and
images to create payloads for
over-the-air update so in this build
step you can create new and many build
configurations and manage them for most
of you you will have just bought or
receive from this i/o the developer kit
to get started you can select the youth
starter kit settings and all the bill
details will be pre-populated for you
for this example though let's walk
through an example of starting from
scratch first one of the most important
thing is to select your underthings OS
version pick the newest version that
you're comfortable with because those
will have the latest bug fixes and
security updates you're not forced to
use them the latest one but it's
recommended for this reason next up in
this step you will see the list of apps
that you have uploaded in the app
library select the apps that you want to
include into your build and don't forget
to include the apps provided by Google
like Google Play services and why would
you want Google Play services with
Google Play services your apps can take
advantage of the latest Google API such
as nearby Maps firebase including the
new animal kit included in the Google
Play service package simply
on the check box you saw in the dialogue
and it will be included in your build
okay so back to the build once you
select your apps take a look at the
permissions those apps are requesting
and make sure that you're okay with them
since your users can't opt into
permissions themselves like with regular
Android it's up to you to do it for them
if you're only using apps that you've
developed yourself there really
shouldn't be any surprises here but if
you're using apps shared from others
it's worth taking a look this is helpful
to prevent the app from doing something
wrong that you weren't expecting and a
good security measure as Android things
gets more common it won't be all that
surprising to see other people building
IOT products with shared apps from
various sources so looking at
permissions is important the next step
is all about adding additional build
resources to your build if your device
has a display you can add a boot
animation as you see here for the Lenovo
smart display you can upload your own
custom boot animation dots it also in
this section we let you choose if you
want to include fonts since a lot of
just devices won't have displays we
don't want to burden them with fonts
it's all about reducing the image size
for these small IOT products now your
Android things device wouldn't be very
interesting if it was just the salm
hardware configures where you add your
peripherals control your GPIO and bus
speed starter kits are pre set up with
the default Hardware configs which we
provide in the starter kit build however
you might want to spice up your
configurations differently you can use
this UI tool to adjust it while this
tool is currently limited to controlling
bus speed and pull-up resistors this is
where in the future you're going to
configure all of your peripherals such
as cameras displays audio buses and
speakers we also plan to give you
control over your i/o here so you could
do pin muxing and determine which tin
which pins are at a touch to which
functions so keep an eye on this space
for more updates in so here you are at
your final bill step you will see that
the configurations you made or display
with their total estimated sizes under
om partition review the estimated size
in summary and set the total size of om
partition as you like you may wonder
what are these partitions and what can I
as a developer change
which partitions are obtainable with
over-the-air update to answer that let's
look at the underthings partition layout
for a moment on the left is the sample
partition layout of imx7 deep eco that's
the board that you got from the
developer kit there are small
differences between the SOC vendors and
boards but let's walk through an example
of partitions that are used by core
underthings architecture which is same
across all songs
starting with system system and boot are
read-only partitions and it's generated
for unused for underthings platform boot
is for carnal and the ramp is for the
normal boot and system is where and
routines OS is loaded VB meta is a
read-only partition and it's used for a
verified boot mechanism as the name
suggests is this is where metadata for
your verify boot is written to
specifically it's a single hash
generated by Google using information of
food system and vendor and signed with a
secure key stored in Google for every
boot sequence of a device bootloader
verifies that the code is authentic and
no known security flaw has been found
using this information devices will not
boot if any tempering has been found so
you don't want to mess around with this
meditation when there is a read-only
partition as well in this partition the
binary image from SOC vendors are loaded
things like driver libraries are
specific to SOC are usually put in here
om and the OEM bootloader or partitions
for underthings developers and that's
you
it's read-only in a sense that after
it's being generated it can not be
tempered for the security reasons I just
talked about but om is a partition where
the contents of the build configuration
that you specified through a console is
written to so in that sense it is
variable and managed by Android things
developers through console this OEM
partition is also generated new when
you're creating the new build for
integration for the OTA and oh yeah
bootloader is a partition where the
hardware can
fusion you might have chosen that
builders ridden too if your Android
developer you might be familiar with
this partition user data this is where
systems and apps will write their user
data at runtime aside from that apks
that you installed through adb install
or the play button in enter studio are
also written into this partition so this
pose is actually a question a package
name is the unique identifier of an app
if the apk even the same package name
exists both in user data and om how
would Android package manager know which
have to be used
om is read only after it's been
generated so the AP keys that are
already written there she still exists
as is when you're developing and you're
most likely going to be changing your IP
case via adb install to honor this
development flow the ad be installed AP
case in user data is always honored over
the ones they know yet so what this
means is if you have AP case and both in
user data in OEM you want to it can
loaded an OEM to work you see will
simply delete the APK and user data by
adb uninstall misc is another read-only
partition are used by platform it's for
miscellanies needs like bootloader and a
system for its functionalities factory
and its bootloader partition is with
it's reserved for any per device
configurations like serial number to be
written as factorize this can also be
done later in service centers this
partition is writable by developers and
factory and it's going to be read only
after it's being shipped so writing to
this partition require special tools and
authorities which we will provide for
you so up to now we've gone over all the
partitions that underthings part core
architecture uses you might have noticed
the partition in this table are
duplicated in two sections a and b like
what do those mean right this is where
the OTA over-the-air update comes in
Oh TA works by a B partition mechanism
where the same partition kind exists in
two duplicates memory spaces this
architecture provides a seamless update
to users where devices can still be
active with the active partition where
the updates are being downloaded and
installed onto the inactive partitions a
B so after all that's done after the
rebooting with a secure boot mechanism
devices will wake up to the partition
where the update has been installed on
to it's also important to note that all
read-only and early things partitions is
fixed at a certain size and as you know
the board memory is also fixed what this
means is that there is a remaining fixed
memory to be split between om partition
and user data partition and you will
decide what the split will be between
the two so let's walk through an example
so say you have chosen
LTS OS couple apps Google Play services
may be custom however configuration in
this console widget view which you saw
at the final build step we took away all
the nitty-gritty details of the system
partitions they have seen so far so if
you haven't been paying attention in the
last slide it's okay all you need to
know is that the system partition is
fixed ah sighs so the OEM partition size
input we asked you to input is going to
be a size of a single om partition so
what this means is when you increase the
size of om partition by 100 the user
data partition will be subtracted by 200
so here is the most important message
about partition that you should take
away from this top
choosing the right om partition size is
important when you're making production
images when devices are baked with the
chosen size they are fixed in the size
layout until they are reflashed
this is because of the nature of a B and
the OTA mechanism we just talked about
so these devices only receive OTA
updates to build with the same
partition size one recommendation though
when setting the size is to leave some
buffer room for future growth you may
want to add new functionality to see
functionality to your apk you may want
to add more like new cool boot animation
which may require more memory so plan
for future and estimate how much you
might want between apps growth versus
the data growth again you don't have
dependent yet when you're prototyping
and development phase you don't have to
worry about finding the right size
because you can always reflash the
device you just need to estimate and
finalize this when you're making of
production images you've now chosen the
right size create the build and with
creative build configuration you can
choose between two image options
development and production development
builds provide debugging capabilities
like ADB and production builders to be
secured and used by end-users thus it
doesn't provide the bugging note that
one's devices are flashed with
production images it cannot be tempered
for security reasons so it needs to be
recovered in order to make it a
debuggable when you click on download
you the image will be generated and the
download will start through the browser
and now you have download the image file
how do I take that from the file to my
devices right and we provide a flash
script tool to make this all super
simple and easy for you simply navigate
to the tool section and download the
script follow the instruction in the
script and it should be all pretty
straightforward and your devices will be
ready to go you can also use fastboot
mode a fast-food instead of the script
if you so wish so with that we've
finished building downloading and
preparing and underthings device right
so up until this point it's been all
about building functionality into your
Android things device and while I know
things makes development easy you
probably could have done the same thing
with a bunch of other IOT platforms out
there but release is where things get
really different updating supporting
pushing new features not just to your
devices but to thousands of devices in
the field this is
for Android things really starts to
shine I like to say that there's two
reasons why you might choose Android
things as an operating system one you
love the power of Android you're
comfortable with it familiar with it or
two you plan to make more than one of
something Amy and I had this had this
laundry robot she has this on a robot
that knows how to fold socks but my
laundry room at my house doesn't know
how to fold Rus fold socks how do we get
that build that she's running onto my
onto my robot with Android things it's
super easy
first off use channels to break up your
device population you might have a few
devices owned by customers a few others
owned by testers and you don't want them
all getting the same bills so put them
on channel so you can segment them
logically you can also create custom
channels say a QA channel or a channel
for people who like the color blue to
further divide things with channels you
can do whatever you want but if you want
some guidance canary is generally the
first devices to get any build it's a
reference to the canary in the coalmine
idiom so if there's anything wrong with
the new build those canary devices will
tell you about it first dev is generally
where developers of Isis sit build up
lots of new functionality plenty of bugs
but at least they boot up beta is for
your testers these are actual users who
are ok getting some new functionality
but giving some feedback about
unreleased software and stable is where
the bulk of your users lives these
builds are heavily tested and everything
should work finally custom is whatever
you want it to be in our developer
previews we got lots of feedback that
people wanted lots of channels to divide
up their device population in different
ways so we created custom channels for
them alright so now that you had these
channels how do you get your devices on
to the channels in the first place
device devices default to the stable
Channel but if you want to change the
channel you can set it via the API or
connect your device and flash it via ADB
as shown up here one thing to keep in
mind remember how Amy talked about
release versus development images you
can flash a device to a new channel if
it's running a development image but if
you're running a public release image
flashing an ADB are blocked so you can't
change the channel either we do this to
prevent end-users from running unwanted
or malicious code on your devices okay
so now that you've assigned that
you could push updates to them you take
the builds that we created earlier
create updates from them and then get
them delivered onto your devices updates
are basically build with new features
bug fixes or changes pushing them to
these devices is called an OTA or an
over the air update devices download
these data these updates and load them
into the B partition once they reboot it
boots into that B partition however if
there's a problem it reverts back to the
a partition I love this because it means
that updates feel instant but they're
also fault tolerant too and everyone on
Android things gets to take advantage of
this one option for OTAs is called
fractional updates rather than push an
update to a hundred percent on your
channel you can roll it out gradually
just to make sure if something bad
happens you're not affecting all your
users at the same time we highly
recommend using fractional updates to
de-risk your OTA approach like I said
earlier nearly all of this technology is
using the same infrastructure that we
use every day to update millions of
devices in the field stuff like a be
updates Delta updates fractional updates
these are all difficult things to get
right but crucially important if you
want reliable updates for your device's
worldwide so like I've Adam mentioned
Andrew things devices follow the same
OTA architecture that Google uses so you
can be confident that it will work but
you might be wondering how does the OTA
work underneath the hood it's pretty
simple flow when you specify through end
routines console we update the OTA
server to hold information about your
product and your update channel and the
devices will report to the OTA server
with its build information every five
hour interval then the OTA server will
let the device's know that you have an
update to pick it up devices download
and install the new updated built into
the inactive a be partition that we
talked about users will be still be able
to use the devices while this printers
process using Update Manager API you can
have full control over the optic policy
such as how often do you want your
devices to ping for the update chart and
also customized device behavior by
listening to update events so let's walk
through an example of a normal update
set of events occurring inside the
device and the following update status
events that are posted to that app
listener update engine will check OTA to
the server and the OTA will server will
let the update engine client know that
there's a new update to pick it up and
it will start the downloading the update
as you can see in this flow diagram the
corresponding update events are posted
to app listener and that's your app
depending on the policy that you set
your app can trigger reboot of the
device when you think it's appropriate
when the device boots up it will start
with the new purchase a new partition
where the update is written to upon upon
reboot it checks for updated game and
because it's already updated it's it
that back at the idle State until the
next update check happens so this is how
you will use the API to set the policy
you can grab the update manager instance
and set the policy you like using apply
only policy Update Manager will download
and install the update whenever a new
update is available and you can change
the update interval frequency using this
API say two days for example but say you
want to control the whole flow then you
can use the check only policy to listen
to all update events and control the
whole update process when you receive
the update available status you can
decide whether it's a good time to start
the download and install and when you
think it is a good time you can trigger
the perform update now a method to
trigger it and when complete you will
get the updated needs reboot status and
also when you think it's a good time you
can trigger the devices to reboot and
it's all gained under your control it's
very possible that your devices will
require a zero-day update when a
customer buys a product after some shelf
time you might have already upgraded
your new software to the next coolest
thing and you want them to start with
that right you don't want users to
download as several gigabytes of the new
software before they can start using
your
a product Delta updates mean this
payload update is as small as possible
basically based on your factory image
options and your previous OTA pushes
under Dean's console we'll take care for
you and generate automatic automatically
generate the Delta payloads between the
builds so devices can then receive the
smaller payloads between their current
build and your new coolest thing imagine
that your friend was unwrapping a
Christmas present and they had to wait
20 minutes to download the latest
version what a terrible experience right
with Delta updates it's so much better
at this point we should probably spend a
little bit of time talking about
security as xkcd so elegantly points out
you don't simply build a secure device
having secured IOT means constantly
maintaining and updating and looking for
vulnerabilities pushing changes
throughout the lifetime of your product
we've talked quite a bit about Andrew
how Android thinks is great when you
want to make a lot of something but when
you make a lot of something do you
really want to be responsible for
pushing new updates throughout the
lifetime of that product Amy and I have
an awesome laundry robot now but maybe
in a few years we go on to do something
else maybe we get different jobs and
then what when we hear about a new
vulnerability do we research kernel and
library fixes maybe we get back together
with all of our engineers and then
compile a new build and push it to our
users no that's not what happens in
reality these orphan devices they live
on connected to the Internet perhaps
unused but really vulnerable thankfully
with Android things we have a solution
for this the auto-update flag because of
our Salm strategy Google can confidently
push security fixes to all IOT use
running devices running that song be it
a laundry folding robot or a webcam
simply flip this chip this flag on your
channel and all your devices will get
regular security updates from Google
with zero involvement from you it's
important to note you aren't required to
flip this flag if you don't enable auto
updates Google will still offer up the
security fixes but you can choose how
and when you want to implement them it's
up to you let Google manage your updates
or control when they roll out yourself
let's talk a little bit about how
Android things updates and versioning
works major versions on Android things
roughly correspond to dessert releases
of normal Android these are large
releases supported for the long term and
represented Android API framework
changes the auto update flag on their
channel does not update across major
versions so if you start on major
version one even what's major version
two is released you'll continue to get
security updates based on major version
one of you so choose the second number
is the minor version these are
comparatively low-risk updates they
don't have any Android API framerate
changes but they do have Android things
API editions if you flip the auto update
flag you can't expect to get updates
across new major versions so if you
start on one point to when the next
minor version rolls out you will migrate
to one point three the last number is
the security update you can expect these
to land approximately every month there
are no API changes and these updates
definitely increment with the auto
update flag on while major versions
updates are optional in exchange for
getting free updates for google we do
expect you to update your versions
across each minor version and security
patch but how you do it is up to you you
can either flip the auto update flag or
push the updates yourself it's our goal
to make Android thing is the easiest and
most secure IOT platform out there
easiest to build and most secure it
up-to-date over the lifetime of your
product so how does this work across
Psalms and major versions and years each
Psalm is supported by Google for a
minimum of three years from the time it
was first made available on every
available major version so if you were
to buy the I MX 8 Psalm and start
building on major version one you can
expect updates for the next three years
all while remaining on major version one
you don't have to update a major version
two to get the full support time of
course we realize that a lot of devices
will need much longer support than those
three years so if you're some supports
it you can update to the next major
version and get a longer support window
your of course always able to push your
own updates for your devices for their
entire lifetime and finally if you're
looking for an even longer support time
come talk to us about some options for
extended support all right so we've
pushed our
these robots can now fall sucks the last
thing to do is step back and monitor how
our robots are doing in the field you
probably want to check out how many
users are there are they using my
devices every day are they getting the
updates that I just pushed or how's my
us robots doing compared to the ones in
Korea under these console provides you
an end-to-end solution all the way to
device analytics with daily activation
and active graph you can monitor how
your devices are doing across your
product you can use time range and
filter to do deeper analysis you can
filter devices by IP countries build IDs
and update channels and so on within an
hour after you push ot8 their console
you can come to this monitored screen to
see how your updates are going if there
are any errors and what stage or your
device is that and the granularity that
we provide is up to every minute you can
monitor various update events such as
update checks various download status
events and finally the reboot event
which tells the device has rebooted to
the new partition these events that you
see here map to the status events you
saw in the update manager API earlier if
there were any errors with the update
you can monitor the update era graph and
drill down to the update error codes to
see if what's going on this is awesome
because right after I push my OTA
I can watch this graph and to see if my
devices are doing well if the release
that I pushed went on smoothly okay so
we just walked you through how to update
your production devices in the field but
let's recap really quickly about why you
should care it's our goal to make IOT
easy and secure with Android things we
put a ton of work into this so you don't
have to we want you to focus on the
stuff that matters your hardware and
software the thing that differentiates
your product and then feel free to lean
on us for firmware security patches and
update infrastructure by using Android
things you can hire regular Android
developers and use familiar tools like
Kotlin and Android studio you get to
take advantage of the same technology
that we use
to update millions of devices in the
field every day you get Delta updates
fractional updates AV partitions and
enhanced monitoring
can you imagine building all of this
yourself I'm sure you could but
something tells me you'd much rather be
developing new features and
functionality than reinventing an update
infrastructure there's also the crucial
piece of security up updates from Google
it's an ideal way to ensure that your
products stay secure with zero
involvement from you four years down the
road in the end we really want to make
it easy to build secure updatable IOT
because we think there's so much
opportunity for new products and ideas
in this space and with that we want to
say thank you for attending our talk on
how to update production devices in the
field with underthings console like we
said before there are many options out
there for IOT in which OS and hardware
you may choose but if you're a
comparable writing Android code Android
things makes it super easy for you to
get started if you book if you plan to
build and sell many devices and if you
care about security as you should and
you want an easy management of your
production devices and readings will be
a great solution for you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]